ma famille Mitterrand si vous voulez
dans son ensemble pas seulement la
famille François j'allais dire est un
peu une tribu et moi je viens de la
tribu
Jean-Christophe merci d'avoir choisi
tout le monde en parle comme première
émission après la sortie de votre livre
donc vous êtes le fils aîné de François
Mitterrand vous avez 55 ans et suite à
une mise en examen dans le cadre d'un
éventuel trafic d'armes en Angola vous
publiez donc un livre vérité intitulé
mémoire meurtri chez plomb vous savez
comment on fait
merci donc on va parler de vous
[Applaudissements]
alors vous êtes né Jean-Christophe
Mitterrand en 46 à Boulogne-Billancourt
en fait vous n'êtes pas l'aîné parce que
on apprend que en disant ce livre que 15
mois avant il y avait eu la mort d'un
enfant en bas âge que ça fait Pascal vos
parents avaient eu un premier enfant et
vous êtes le frère de Gilbert Mitterrand
et votre père a eu un autre enfant
évidemment qui est Mazarine pas avec la
même mère avec Anne pincheux voilà alors
vous dites je suis né tendre dans une
famille qui l'était guère ça veut dire
quoi ça
la famille notre famille est une famille
un peu j'allais dire comme c'est dû dans
le livre je suis pensionnaire
pratiquement toute ma scolarité donc
isolé et je veux dire c'est un isolement
qui
me faisait des bleus à l'âme ouais et
puis en plus il faut remettre dans le
contexte nous sommes nettement avant 68
et c'était pas la même éducation
bon on déjeunait on dit n'est pas avec
les parents ou quand on était invité à
la table où il y avait des invités en
général le week-end
les enfants n'avaient pas le droit de
parler enfin c'était une éducation un
peu stricte oui je suis le moins
Mitterrand de toute la famille pourquoi
à cause de la taille mesure 1m82 c'est
vrai que vous êtes beaucoup plus grand
que le reste de la famille c'est vrai
mais il y a pas que ça non non
ma famille Mitterrand si vous voulez
dans son ensemble pas seulement la
famille François j'allais dire est un
peu une tribu et moi je viens de la
tribu donc je suis le moins présent le
fils d'à côté le fils d'à côté c'est une
image que j'ai priori alors bon assez
comme ça assez tourmenté assez rebelles
dès votre plus jeune âge première fugue
à l'âge de 10 ans la nuit dans les
jardins du Luxembourg je passais entre
les barreaux vos parents habitaient rue
Guynemer à l'époque donc
écolier étudiant réfractaire et vous
dites en parlant de votre scolarité
difficile de de faire avancer un âne qui
recule oui je faisais que ce que je
voulais donc je n'étudie que les
matières qui m'intéressaient il y en
avait pas beaucoup je le reconnais il y
avait les maths et l'histoire c'est tout
oui il faisait des maths pour vous
amuser vous c'est comme les autres font
des mots croisés exactement faisait des
maths
alors bon père absent évidemment votre
père François Mitterrand très absorbé
voire bouffé par sa carrière politique
et quand on vous a appelé plus tard papa
m'a dit vous dites en fait il m'a pas
expliqué la vie en tous les cas mais non
puisque d'abord je n'étais pas là on se
voyait que pendant les vacances ou
lorsqu'ils venait voir en pension et en
général on avait pas beaucoup le temps
enfin quant à votre mère elle venait pas
vous voir souvent en pensant vous le
dites
vous écrivez peut-être supposé tel que
passer toutes les vacances avec elle mon
frère et Jean anami suffisait à mon
bonheur vous avez le sentiment étant
enfant comme ça d'être assez délaissé
vous révéler quelque chose c'est que
quand j'ai écrit ce livre évidemment je
lui ai fait lire au moment où avant
qu'il soit imprimé et à la réagi sur
cette phrase et elle m'a expliqué vous
voyez 50 ans après ou 40 ans après elle
m'a expliqué que c'était le directeur de
la pension dont je parle qui demandait à
la famille de ne pas venir pour
forcer les enfants à sortir de leur
milieu et à travailler donc
nous avons eu une explication et 50 ans
plus tard on avait on a compris c'est
tout parce que votre mère elle a plutôt
bon coeur est toujours là
absolument pas de ma mère alors bon
ambiance pas terrible pas terrible à la
maison
vos parents pour s'entendaient pas très
bien aussi on s'en doute jamais été
témoin de quoi que ce soit ce sujet là
oui mais votre mère quand même
communiqué avec votre père en déposant
des LED sur son oreiller non pas à cette
époque là c'était surtout dans les
dernières années
quand j'avais des discussions politiques
un peu tendues elle trouvait qu'il était
trop à droite sans doute un peu et en
même temps effectivement votre percer
votre père donc le 19 décembre 1965 le
jour de vos 19 ans il obtient 45% contre
le général de Gaulle le deuxième tour
donc c'est effectivement énorme quoi
d'un seul coup ça vous est tombé dessus
et vous dites en parlant de lui ça
l'emportait dans un monde
qui n'était pas le mien et qui me
restera toujours étranger vous dites oui
parce que c'est pas mon monde alors
votre père évidemment c'était le chef
des antigolistes et vous au lycée vous
en souffriez non il y avait quand même
des il y a des colibiers des insultes
des bagarres bien sûr il y en avait vous
savez des coups les cours de l'école
sont des endroits durs mais surtout qui
avait l'affaire l'Observatoire qui est
mon père s'était fait tirer dessus en 59
nous c'est un bien et c'était à 200
mètres même pas 200 mètres de la porte
du lycée alors évidemment le lendemain
vous voyez ça
c'était un peu tendu alors bon voilà
vous êtes un petit peu vos collègues à
l'école vous embête un peu vous vous
réfugiez dans l'imaginaire dans le
silence oui j'étais assez silencieux oui
refermez un peu sous vous-même
alors à 19 ans donc c'est là je suis de
votre premier amour
c'est là où j'ai commencé les premiers
oui pour me laisser pousser c'était pas
prévu au départ mais bon voilà
non pas beaucoup non à New York et puis
après on Israël vous voyez il y a eu
quelques années entre les deux et puis
depuis plus du tout certains d'Israël
vous avez été obligé d'avaler un pétard
oui il y avait des centres de flics
avec la police Jamel je fumais plus par
convivialité que par goût
disons que dans mes dans mes rencontres
après il y en avait moins qui fumaient
d'accord voilà on a pas eu l'occasion de
se rencontrer non mais moi je fume pas
du tout
non sérieux je fume pas du tout
si vous assistez
[Musique]
vous posez la question sur le cabanisme
bien alors là à New York vous tombez
sous le charme de Leslie Bogart qui est
la fille d'homme frais Bogart et de
Lauren Bacall et un jour vous allez la
chercher à la maison comment ça se passe
je n'avais encore jamais rencontré
Lauren Bacall je monte les escaliers bon
c'était c'était surnommé de look quand
même
et je me dis bon je vais sonner elle va
m'ouvrir et j'étais un peu déçu vous
allez nous faire croire que vous avez
failli pécher Lauren Bacall
moi je dis pas que c'est à cause des
pétards mais peut-être
non c'est vrai que vous découvrez une
femme peu grande comme ça
elle était chez elle elle a été chez
elle
et bon ben elle correspondait pas tout à
fait à l'image qu'on a dans les films
mais je suis sûr quand ça prétend et en
s'habillant elle aurait de retrouver
cette image là comme nous tous et la
fille comment elle était alors Leslie
Bogart sympa sympa
comme beaucoup les deux
ressembler qu'à sa mère ça aurait été
mieux bon un an plus tard vous rentrez
en France c'est c'est mai 68 j'ai le
look Baba non un peu oui vous avez
débarqué chez François Mitterrand avec
les cheveux longs
indienne mais vous savez les Ray-Ban à
l'époque c'était le début elles étaient
un peu tombé du camion aussi tu vois que
j'ai des points communs
qui tombent du camion moi je suis du 7 8
dans un premier temps
vous voulez parler
bien sûr les Yvelines
148 mai 68
alors votre père veut que vous fassiez
science pot et vous vous êtes pas du
tout envie c'était pas la mode à
l'époque c'est vrai au concours vous
rendez la feuille blanche quand même
vous étiez vraiment après caution de
tout le réussir hein
prenons toutes les précautions rendant
la feuille blanche vérité j'étais déjà
inscrit à la faculté de Vincennes
effectivement en histoire-géo
et là votre père vous souffle c'était
votre pour un UV pour obtenir la fin du
V qui nous a donné comme sujet c'est
insensé ça c'est très Mitterrand c'est
très François mitter quand vous dit vous
savez vous avez 20 ans vous dit
choisissez un sujet d'histoire politique
alors j'en parle à mon père comme ça au
coin d'un couloir il me dit bah il y a
un sujet génial qui est la notion de la
notion d'Etat au travers de savonarol
Laurent le Magnifique et Machiavel
après vous avez un Israël
qui boots un bouton des moutons vous
ramassez des pamplemousses plutôt sympa
comme expérience
un des amis que j'ai là-bas m'a demandé
de ramener quelques saucissons quand
même
bon ça devient un une famille de
substitution pour vous vous dites on
était à table on parlait c'est un
village communautaire si vous voulez on
vit en groupe et c'est pas désagréable
je ne sais pas si j'aurai passé ma vie
c'est là-bas que vous avez l'air un
joint entier non c'est pas qui goûte
dans une boîte et c'était en vérité
c'était dans un café et
un descente de flics j'avais un joint
sur moi je l'ai avalé ensuite une petite
caméra quand même
et ensuite par précaution
et ensuite on est allé en boîte je me
souviens pas très bien ce qui s'est
passé c'est ce qui arrive quand on
est bon puis toujours cette idée de
s'expatrier quand même toujours ça c'est
récurrent chez vous parce que ça a été
toute votre vie c'est fou vous
choisissez la coopération vous allez
d'abord dans le Sud algérien c'est là
que vous rencontrez votre femme
Elisabeth qui vient vous voir un jour
vous découvrez l'Afrique et après vous
retournez quand vous bossez pour l'AFP
vous retournez en Afrique
Nouakchott Lomé voilà alors en 80 vous
faites la campagne de le père à l'île de
la Réunion et quand il est élu président
de la République vous pensez un peu
naïvement qui sera aucune importance sur
votre vie c'est vrai totalement
naïvement c'est vrai je pense que je
vais pouvoir continuer à être
journaliste tranquillement que j'ai ma
vie quoi que je repartirai en poste
à l'étranger
j'étais prêt moi faire ma carrière à
l'agence presse et en fait vous
découvrez assez rapidement que le que le
regard des autres sur vous change
terriblement déjà en tant que
journaliste je n'ai plus aucune
crédibilité je sais pas pourquoi l'AFP
vous êtes mis sur la touche complètement
j'ai plus le droit d'écrire
le fait que mon père soit président de
la République
d'ailleurs même encore aujourd'hui il y
a un ancien de l'AFP que j'ai rencontré
qui me dit mais on pouvait pas imaginer
que tu puisses écrire un papier sur la
politique étrangère de la France et
pourquoi pas ouais vous avez dit par
exemple je n'ai pas appris à lire à
écrire par piston je suis pas plus con
qu'un autre et pourtant vous étiez barré
quoi tout le monde dit il est né avec
une cuillère en argent dans la marge
dans la bouche il a eu tout même la
rentrée à l'AFP c'est un piston même je
sais pas tout est par piston
Jean-Christophe la carrière politique
nous a jamais tenté jamais non jamais
jamais au contraire même plutôt
repousser donc après ben voilà vous êtes
viré de l'AFP vous allez la cellule
Afrique c'est une Afrique de l'Élysée et
puis ça continue vous dites ne pas
appartenir au sérail était une gageure
je dû payer l'addition et mon père le
pourboire c'est à dire que vraiment vous
êtes accusés alors là on commence à vous
accuser tous les mots on vous accuse
d'afférize la République des copains et
des coquins le site en exemple en de
fêtard on dit bois sans arrêt bon voilà
de baisers
alors vous parlez de ça j'en ai partout
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque moi aussi
j'étais j'étais sensible à ça parce
qu'elle n'avait plein les journaux de
toute façon donc oui mais à ce point
j'étais sur
vous dites d'ailleurs c'est pas parce
qu'on allait boire un coup dans une
boîte qu'on baisait à courir abattu non
c'est un ami à moi qu'elle se
vocabulaire c'est pas moi qui a dit
cette phrase mais c'était un ami qui
venait avec moi de temps en temps ouais
c'est vrai Jamel qui se ressemble ça
sent bon je vous présenterai d'accord
avec plaisir et là votre votre couple
explose quoi oui oui
on avait ton mari avec une telle que je
connaissais pas d'ailleurs ça va très
vite
c'est des gens ils ont pas que ça à
[__] d'ailleurs à Paris et vous
découvrez alors le pire de tous et que
vous découvrez que c'est un vieil ami de
votre père François de Grossouvre il
balançait à des journalistes pierre
Péant qui d'ailleurs fait la préface de
votre livre et qui dit j'ai été
intoxiqué par ce type
je me souviens très bien on disait que
vous cultiviez des champs de pavot
Rwanda Rwanda alors vous savez c'est
vrai ça ou pas déjà la déjà vous
connaissez le Ronda un petit peu ah bon
et ben c'est des endroits les plus
peuplés au monde
densité et il n'y a pas un hectare par
famille
je connaissais pas le Ronda plus qu'un
autre en fait l'histoire c'est que ce
François de Grossouvre avait été un
petit peu marginalisé par votre père il
était un peu comme une amoureuse déçue
comme une maîtresse répudier et il se
vengeait en vous faisant du mal à vous
et en essayant d'en faire à mon père
évidemment mais il faut savoir que au
début lorsqu'il a été nommé les et il
était le correspondant à l'Élysée des
services spéciaux c'est-à-dire des GSE
DST etc il avait ce fantasme là complet
de patron de la DGSE il n'a pas été
c'était pour lui un acte de comment dire
de méfiance à son égard il n'a jamais
digéré puis je crois qu'après il a
disjoncté mais vous savez la prochaine
pouvoir beaucoup de gens disjonctent
voilà puis vous parlez dans votre
bouquin aussi de la cour de François
Mitterrand alors donc il y avait charade
il y avait langue avec qui je Magne il y
avait merma Fabius vous les avez revu
tous ces gens là quand vous avez eu des
problèmes ils sont venus vous aider
certains oui bien sûr la plupart la
plupart vous étiez à lattes le soir ou
Georges Marc Benhamou a vu votre père se
gaver d'ortolan et vous mettez les
choses au point dans votre bouquin vous
dites que en fait Benhamou avait été
accepté malgré votre mère qui était pas
très d'accord pour qu'il vienne non non
parce qu'il était avec Pierre Berger en
fait il n'était pas invité ah oui c'est
parce qu'il est arrivé avec Pierre
Berger
on perd voulait refuser mais par à cause
de Pierre Berger et pour ne pas gêner
puis un berger il a quand même accepté
mais il voulait créer clash ouais pas
donc pas à cause de Pierre Berger tout
le monde a été mis un petit peu devant
le fait accompli voilà voilà il a fallu
dans cette soirée il a il l'a raconté
dans un bouquin vous vous dites on n'a
pas du tout vécu la même soirée non on
devait pas être dans la même pièce au
même endroit est-ce que vous pensez que
ça handicap alors les révélations de
George Marc Benhamou dans son dernier
livre sur le lobby juif par exemple
peut-être peut-être
je ne sais pas mais moi ça
j'allais dire il a vécu Assinie s'est
fait un cinéma quoi
et puis il a sorti un livre très vite
alors bon finissez par quitter l'Élysée
à force d'être emmerdé par les racontars
contrairement à ce qu'on a dit c'est pas
mon père qui m'a viré oui moi accepter
votre démission très intéressant
d'ailleurs c'est vrai qu'on pensait que
vous allez virer un moment il n'en
pouvait pas du tout vous voulez que vous
restiez vous alors vous partez à la
Générale des eaux qui est devenu vivant
dit mais c'est terrible vie parce qu'en
mai 95 quand Chirac était lu votre clé
de licenciement est déjà prête
la coïncidence est quand même importante
c'est pas compliqué votre père est mort
le 8 janvier 96 et le jour des obsèques
votre bureau était vidée
en vérité la lettre de licenciement a
été signée donc en mai quelque chose
comme ça
j'ai négocié de partir en décembre comme
laisse le temps de me retourner et on
m'avait proposé même de garder le bureau
physiquement
un mois de plus pour
et bon mon père meurt le 8 je suis aux
obsèques devant toutes les télévisions
etc et quand je reviens les cartons avec
mes affaires étaient sur le trottoir
enfin ils étaient pas sur le trottoir
parce que quelqu'un les avait ramassés
mais voilà et la serrure est échangé
alors là vous partez en Mauritanie
monter monter une affaire un Nouakchott
un épisode de Dallas
exactement et moi je suis qui Bobby
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maison même
mais le pire était à venir donc vous
allez à Nouakchott et puis un jour voilà
un jour on vient vous enfin vous êtes en
France de pour un petit voyage en France
où vous vous êtes résident en fait en
Mauritanie 96 je me suis installé en
Mauritanie je peux apporter l'épreuve de
mon installation en partie 97 parce que
avant c'était chez les amis à l'hôtel
maintenant un loyer de téléphone etc et
on a monté une affaire de
valorisation de produits de la pêche
voilà exactement
et je revenais j'étais
en décembre début décembre j'étais à
Paris et perquisition qui arrive
et le 21 je suis convoqué par la brigade
financière et je me suis retrouvé en
prison voilà
et je suis je suis venu à la brigade
financière en venant du Sénégal où je
m'étais rendu entre-temps pour le
travail pour le travail à l'histoire la
caution vous met en taule on vous
demande 5 millions pour vous laisser
sortir vous fusée de payer pourquoi
je refuse de payer il faut comprendre ce
que c'est une caution
elle est divisée en deux parties il y a
4 millions et un million il y a 4
millions et millions un million pour
être sûr que je ne fuis pas bon c'est à
dire si je prends la poudre d'escantage
je perds
ça se trouve pas sur le pied d'un cheval
déjà
et 4 millions qui sont les amendes que
j'aurais à payer si je suis coupable
c'est à dire que je suis préjugé
coupable déjà il faut que je paye parce
que je suis préjugé coupable et pour
pouvoir sortir de prison et en plus on
ajoute que je ne peux pas sortir avant
que la caution soit payée c'est à dire
je crois je prends le téléphone dans la
cellule il y a pas le téléphone
j'aurais pas eu ma mère disons que j'ai
formidable
et les amis et les amis qu'elle a
mobilisés je serai encore parce que
je raconte même que que je lui donne mon
paquet de cigarettes je ne pensais pas
une seconde rendu compte que j'ai en
prison soi-même que j'allais sortir pour
prendre j'allais racheter j'en avais
plus je lui donne il y avait des tips il
savait pas pourquoi ils étaient là
ah c'est ça moi je peux vous en citer
des noms
je suis sûr que que depuis 9 mois il
demande pourquoi hier alors la justice
vous soupçonne d'être impliquée dans un
éventuel trafic d'armes en Angola ce
qu'on appelle l'Angola gate aujourd'hui
alors autour de Pierre Falcone qui était
un homme d'affaires de droite donc est
toujours en toujours en prison depuis le
1er décembre 2000 en détention
provisoire c'est vrai que dans 9 mois
parce que ce qui est terrible dans ces
affaires c'est que vous faites deux ans
de préventive pas de provisoire et puis
après quand vous sortez vous êtes
condamné un an vous avez fait un an de
trop on vous le rembourse pas exactement
et même un ennemi trop parce qu'en
général le fait que la moitié de la
peine
VIP
vous avez vu qui là-bas il y a toujours
des stars qui arrivait
on était dans deux cellules face à face
et c'est des portes vitrées
j'allais en prison et lui aller au jus
personne est à l'abri
Jean-Christophe pierre Falcon il vous a
quand même versé 1,8 millions de dollars
quand même pas un seul coup
et j'étais intéressé à ces bénéfices
j'ai travaillé avec lui j'étais pas payé
en honoraire j'étais payé selon les
bénéfices on n'aurait pas eu j'aurais
touché zéro d'accord il y a des
bénéfices mais ils vont donner une
partie 1,8 millions de dollars ça
provenait de quoi de Van Damme non
l'Angola en dehors de ces crises
politiques intérieures n'avait plus
aucune possibilité d'emprunter de
l'argent l'état anglais vous savez que
la France entraîne tous les jours
n'avait plus aucune possibilité
d'emprunter de l'argent du cash quoi
et de poupée donc faire d'achat je parle
pas d'achat
pierre Falcon a eu l'idée
de monter des poules financiers qui
traitait financier privé j'allais dire
des banques qui prêtaient de l'argent à
l'Angola d'accord garantie sur la
production pétrole d'accord vous avez
aidé à ça oui et vous avez un million de
dollars sur ces bénéfices d'accord ok
alors là où il y a une connerie quand
même faut bien le dire c'est que vous
l'argent vous le mettez sur un compte en
Suisse je travaille à l'étranger ah oui
je travaille je n'ai jamais sorti
l'argent de France
vous le mettez en Suisse parce que rien
compte en Suisse depuis 92 à l'époque je
travaillais pour une société installée à
Genève qui m'a amené dans une banque de
Genève pour me dire ouvrez un compte là
pour qu'on puisse vous payer bien nous
travaillons suisses donc c'est normal
que vous ayez j'avais oui parce que tu
poses la question il y a rien dit légal
parce que je voulais savoir si l'argent
qui est arrivé en Suisse était parti de
France ou d'ailleurs il est pas parti je
n'ai depuis 96 c'est à dire
depuis 96 depuis que je quitte la
Générale des Eaux je n'ai jamais
travaillé avec une société française
parce que on sait que tu subis une
injustice tu subis la justice il y a des
preuves
Rwanda la Suisse la France l'Amérique on
parle de dollars ça transfert par la
Suisse c'est quand même un peu compliqué
cette histoire
je suis de votre côté et puis j'ai le
droit de gagner de l'argent au travail
c'est normal comme tout le monde
finalement Jean-Christophe
vous avez fait de la prison
ça vous rapproche j'ai jamais fait de
présent de ma vie moi
non mais sérieux quoi
[Applaudissements]
mais j'ai vu le passage où vous étiez
passé chez les juges et c'est pour tout
le monde la même en fait hein
ouais c'est ça le truc
alors que c'est illégal ouais je vais
vous dire ce qui est terrible c'est que
en fait vous êtes là vous avez une
première mise en examen bon qui a été en
fait ça a été annulé bon et puis les
enfants une deuxième mise en examen il
vous faut rester en France juste pour
passer une fois chez le juge quoi
ça fait 9 mois que j'ai pas de
passeports on vous garde ici juste pour
vous interviewer vous interroger pardon
une fois de temps en temps voilà et
toutes les semaines je dois aller chez
les gendarmes pour bien montrer je suis
pas parti
on vous arracher parce que le ministre
de la Défense n'avait pas porté plainte
c'est ça voilà
mais après
il a fini par porter plainte il a fini
par porter en disant en disant la
première lettre de sa plainte et la
première phrase de sa plainte c'est pour
aider à l'instruction en cours je porte
plainte ce qui est déjà surréaliste
parce que la struction me peut exister
que s'il y a plainte
vous avez vu et vous allez pécho sa
femme ou quoi lui c'est pas possible
enfin il avait pas de raison de le faire
c'est juste histoire de c'était juste
des parapluies en politique
en plus enfin je sais pas vous
travaillez plus en France vous étiez en
dehors de tout ça pourquoi ça vous
retombe c'est ça que j'arrive pas à
comprendre moi aussi si vous trouvez la
réponse rien
rien j'ai travaillé pendant 10 ans avec
mon père par rapport à l'Afrique c'est
tout pourquoi déranger autant laisser ça
on sait des choses soit on
dans ses talents d'hommes d'affaires a
déranger les gens lui par contre je ne
sais pas bien la ferme c'est à dire que
Mazarine la remonte un petit peu dans
dans le temps évidemment il y a quelques
années vous vous subodorez son existence
vous n'êtes pas sûr que votre père a eu
cet enfant votre mère on entend
tellement de rumeurs et tout surtout
qu'on se dit encore une vous savez si on
est si je croyais à toutes les rumeurs
je crois que j'aurais au moins 15 frères
et sœurs
votre mère le savait parce qu'il y a une
bonne copine qui lui avait dit le jour
de la naissance de Mazarine qu'il avait
appelé pour lui dire
ma mère l'a pris comme ça sympa
donc vous vous en parliez jamais et puis
en 93 vous décidez de rompre l'omerta
familial et vous demandez à votre père
de vous la présenter voilà et vous dites
davantage de fébrilité pour monter le
rendez-vous que pour organiser un G7 il
m'a jamais été appelé en quelques jours
c'était toutes les deux heures pour être
sûr que le rendez-vous était bien telle
heure pour elle c'est fébrile oui
c'était plutôt sympathique oui
à 17 ans à l'époque elle vous raconte sa
vie de jeune fille quoi vous découvrez
une une demi-soeur comme ça elle
découvrait un grand frère un très grand
fan ça s'est bien passé très très bien
très très bien avec pas mal d'émotions
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on peut pas dire
quand même que vous je connais pas
Gilbert votre frère mais vous on a
l'impression que vous étiez quand même
un petit peu écrasé par la personnalité
de votre père alors que Mazarine a
l'impression qu'elle s'est nourrie de
votre père écrasé il faut pas exagérer
quand même non les termes mais mon père
nous a eu mon frère et moi il avait 30
ans il avait sa carrière à faire
il avait son travail il était alors
général vous savez les hommes entre 30
40 ans sont complètement pris dans leur
boulot là il a eu Mazarine il avait plus
de 60 ou 60 ans à peu près c'était une
fille il a fait sa carrière il était
presque président parce que c'était
juste avant j'allais plus de temps lui
il avait du temps à lui conseiller il y
avait pas de question d'avoir une
jalousie à son égard
et puis en plus j'avais 40 ans j'avais
pas être jaloux
alors tout la famille fait connaissance
aux obsèques de François Mitterrand
et je vous ai prévu depuis vous vous
voyez
pas très souvent parce que j'allais dire
d'abord moi j'y vais à l'étranger et
deuxièmement on est quand même de
générations très différentes on n'a pas
les mêmes copains on a parlé non mais on
se voit bien sûr avec plaisir alors
aujourd'hui vous habitez rue de Bièvre
avec votre mère mais oui je suis en
comment on peut dire en résidence
provisoire
[Musique]
dans un très vieil appartement
rue sarrasin
je te le dis pour la prochaine fois mais
c'est pas vrai parce que dans cette
d'abord on n'habite pas la même
appartement puisque
on est voisin de palier ou François
le rez-de-chaussée et ma nièce qui a le
deuxième étage donc nous vivons en clan
à l'italienne vous avez changé le lit
c'est tout oui pourquoi il était pas
bien le lit tu es peut-être trop petit
pour vous le dit non
peut-être en fait disons que j'ai mis un
lit à moi
alors votre père un jour voilà il est
sur le point de mourir il a les yeux
mi-clos comme ça vous vous approchez de
lui il est en pleine agonie et il vous
dit excuse-moi je t'ai fait beaucoup de
mal oui
j'ai beaucoup hésité à le mettre dans le
livre ça parce que c'est un moment à moi
et
c'est qu'il est très sincère oui il est
très sincère
j'ai pas de règlement de compte à régler
vous savez
avec ce qui m'est arrivé la prison et
tout ça pendant que j'étais en prison
notamment il y a eu des tombes
d'informations qui tournent tomber sur
moi on me refaitait ma vie
sans jamais me demander mon avis ni les
mêmes essayer de confirmer
bon j'en ai eu plusieurs de vie vous nez
de le raconter en sortant je me suis dit
il faut peut-être que
donne ma version
et j'avais un très joli titre que je
pouvais plus prendre parce qu'il était
pris c'était ma part de vérité
le pire le pire excuse-moi je sais pas
si vous avez vécu la même chose que moi
une autre échelle c'est quand les médias
s'emparent de votre histoire j'ai quand
même lu des dans la presse des endroits
où j'aurais été où je suis jamais allé
ma vie avec des gens que j'ai avec qui
j'ai parlé et on rapporte ce que j'ai
dit
j'ai jamais rencontré de ma vie
et ça passe et ça reste dans les
archives de tous les journalistes qu'il
ressortent puisqu'il ne vérifie pas
à toutes ces canards alors quand votre
père vous dit excuse-moi je t'ai fait du
mal il pense à quoi alors il faut que je
vous dise dans quel circonstance c'était
donc c'était 3 jours avant sa mort il
était assez mal je crois à peu près que
c'est le dernier entretien clair qu'il a
eu quelqu'un après il est un peu tombé
dans le coma si vous voulez enfin et on
parlait de la vie de la famille des
choses de la vie des choses de la mort
aussi et on a parlé la période et
lycéenne et on a parlé de Grossouvre
comme ça il s'interrogeait beaucoup sur
le suicide de deux gros sourds
et puis bien sûr de ce qui de ce qui
m'avait fait
et
à ce moment-là il m'a dit excuse-moi
je t'ai fait beaucoup de mal je l'ai
compris comme j'ai pas fait suffisamment
attention au mal qu'on pouvait faire
j'ai laissé courir les rumeurs j'aurais
pu peut-être me battre plus vous
éteignez chez vous ici aussi
[Musique]
Jean-Christophe Mitterrand vous avez
quoi à dire à votre père ce soir
[Musique]
que je pense beaucoup à lui que je
l'aime et que je regrette qu'on soit
quand j'étais jeune un peu raté merci on
rallume
[Applaudissements]
un peu un peu plus gai vous avez jamais
voulu faire de politique vous avez
jamais voulu être président donc on va
faire une interview si j'étais président
en bouche pas pendant les jingles
[Applaudissements]
qui prendriez vous pour réécrire les
paroles de la Marseillaise moi elle est
morte ça aurait été dit Piaf Édith Piaf
Joey Starr
[Applaudissements]
qui prendriez vous comme stagiaire à
l'Elysée je crois que j'aurais pris des
inconnus ah ouais ouais
selon leurs compétences vous êtes
président de la République le dalaï-lama
mais c'est un grand ami de ma mère on
est entre nous alors donc le delaï-lama
donc vient à Paris et si vous le recevez
la Chine annule une commande de 80
Airbus faites quoi
si je suis président ouais évidemment ça
poserait le problème de de l'industrie
d'Airbus
80 Airbus ça fait du pognon oui ça fait
énormément de pognon et ça fait surtout
beaucoup d'emplois
c'est vrai que le problème se poserait
je pense que ma mère me ferait une
comédie comme elle en a fait à votre
père et je crois que c'est des choses
qui peuvent se négocier voilà dans votre
façon de vivre si vous étiez président
qu'est-ce qui embarrasserait le plus vos
conseillers en communication
en indépendance
vous savez avec mon père lui président
il nous est arrivé de partir dîner sans
sécurité sans rien au couscous du coin
les gens étaient un peu surpris et
surtout la sécurité qu'il a appris
qu'après
qui prendriez vous comme conseiller
spirituel
pas besoin pas besoin
quel profession inviteriez-vous à petit
déjeuner chez vous à l'Élysée
plusieurs j'espère que je suis pas
président qu'un seul jour donc il y
aurait plusieurs petits déjeuners pour
la suite des avocats sûrement peut-être
pas tous mais des avocats sûrement et
peut-être des juges aussi pour le
rappeler le droit c'est aussi président
est-ce que vous achèteriez vos billets
d'avion en liquide
j'ai été à l'Élysée j'ai jamais vu de
liquide quand je voulais prendre un
billet d'avion j'appelais le service des
voyages officiels en disant j'ai besoin
d'un billet d'avion point et ils avaient
un chèque et tout Jamel
je me demandais si si le roi du Maroc ou
président de la République avait du
liquide sur bien sûr
normalement pas à titre personnel les
fonds secrets non enfin bon ils peuvent
servir
en même temps dernière question pour
l'entretien télévisé du 14 juillet quel
journaliste inviteriez-vous pour vous
interviewer les grandes chaînes donc
c'est eux qui décident le journaliste
qu'ils envoient pourquoi vous aimez pas
les questions indiscrètes et c'est vrai
qu'au dernier 14 juillet est pas
beaucoup et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de Inna larditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu